so Bernie Sanders has been getting very
very severely smeared recently and most
of the smears have been sort of general
predictable smears in the context of the
2020 primary so stuff like Bernie's not
really a Democrat or Bernie's just
another white dude and that's not what
we need right now or Bernie's ideas
aren't really unique anymore because
they've become mainstreamed partially
thanks to Bernie in the 2016 election
and now a lot of candidates have many of
Bernie's ideas in 2020 or Bernie's
divisive in the DNC or Bernie handed the
election to Trump in 2016 and we could
talk about every single one of those
comments assertion smears attacks call
them what you want but that's not what
I'm going to talk about today I want to
talk specifically about Bernie Sanders
getting smeared for obviously correct
statements about Venezuela which should
not even be controversial and they
wouldn't be were it not for this enclave
of the left called the Leninist left or
as I call it the Leninist left and
before I get to these Venezuela comments
from Bernie let me remind you the
Leninist left back in 2016
also smeared Bernie over his position on
the israeli-palestinian conflict there
was an event I forget exactly when in
the campaign it was relatively early
though and Bernie was asked a question
from the audience about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and Bernie
said something pretty logical and not
super controversial which is we have to
be doing something to help the
Palestinians we have to be doing
something to improve the conditions for
Palestinians that are living in the
region and we simultaneously have to
remember that Israel also is allowed to
it defend itself and you could disagree
with exactly where the line should be
drawn but it is a very milquetoast
uncontroversial statement and he was
smeared as an islamaphobe he was smeared
as just another Jewish Israeli shill the
thinly veiled anti
semitism came forward but it's like hold
on a second that was a completely
rational statement why was Bernie
smeared for that
so let's now get to Venezuela I've been
telling you for I mean a month or longer
in this recent news cycle but really for
years that progressives should not
support Nicolas Maduro progressives
should not support Hugo Chavez Maduro is
a disaster he has plundered and
distorted and he is an authoritarian and
I'm a progressive so I oppose him but
that doesn't mean that I'm in favor of
American intervention in Venezuela
American intervention in Venezuela is
something I'm against just over the
weekend I got emails from people saying
David I can't believe you favor American
intervention in Venezuela and I actually
I rarely respond to people other than on
the show but I wrote back to a couple
people saying can you point me to a
video where I say I'm in favor of
American intervention in Venezuela
because I'm not I'm against it
people on the right tend to disagree
with me because they want the United
States to get involved in Venezuela
people on the Leninist Left disagree
with me because they sometimes idolized
Hugo Chavez and Nicolas Maduro so that
that's me just to kind of set this up in
comes Bernie Sanders and he tells us his
view and it's effectively identical to
my view and he's getting crushed for it
I mean just absolutely obliterated by
elements of the left on on Twitter and
on the Internet so let's first start
with Bernie's tweets on January 24th
about this issue Bernie Sanders the most
progressive member of the US Senate said
about the situation in Venezuela quote
the Maduro government has waged a
violent crackdown on Venezuelan civil
society true violated the Constitution
by dissolving the National Assembly
that's correct
and was reelected last year in an
election many observers said was
fraudulent that's absolutely accurate
the economy is a disaster that's correct
and millions are migrating absolutely
correct estimated ten percent of the
Venezuelan population has left the
country Bernie goes on the united states
should support the rule of law fair
elections and self-determination for the
Venezuelan people that does not mean
American involvement we must condemn the
use of violence against unarmed
protesters that's absolutely correct and
the suppression of dissent and then
Bernie goes on to finish by saying but
and this is important we must learn the
lessons of the past and not be in the
business of regime change or supporting
couz as we have done as we have in Chile
Guatemala Brazil and the Dominican
Republic the United States has a long
history of inappropriately intervening
in Latin American nations we must not go
down that road again absolutely and
completely correct on every single level
those tweets were not as noticed maybe
as this next one that Bernie tweeted
over this past weekend where he added to
his commentary on Venezuela saying the
people of Venezuela are enduring a
serious humanitarian crisis that's
correct
Nicolas Maduro denies it but they are
the Maduro government must put the needs
of its people first allow humanitarian
aid into the country and refrain from
violence against protein protesters
obviously all corrects now before we
even get into the analysis of the smears
that bernie is on the receiving end of
as a result of these tweets let me first
just say I I applaud Bernie for talking
about this many 20/20 candidates
Democratic candidates have been avoiding
talking about this my guess is because
they are worried that if they just speak
their mind the way Bernie did they will
be called either socialists or they will
be called inline with the Trump Pro
intervention pro coup get involved and
take their oil side which of course
bernie is not and i am not and it
shouldn't be so controversial merely to
say this now on the facts
Bernie's just right here I mean there's
been a violent crackdown against
Venezuelan civil society there's an
election that is widely alleged to have
been fraudulent there's suppression of
dissent
we are against regime change if we are
progressives if we are progressives
there can be no way to be supportive of
the Maduro regime and we also should not
be supportive of regime change now on
this program I'm very careful not to
make this a show about we're on the Left
but we primarily criticize the left that
that's I don't like that idea
okay I criticize whoever deserves
criticism it's mostly the right but
sometimes it's the left on this issue a
portion of the left is failing
there can't be left-wing apologetics for
authoritarian regimes it doesn't matter
if they have socialistic rhetoric or
capitalistic rhetoric or theocratic
rhetoric progressives shouldn't do
apologetics for authoritarian regimes
there are some Leninist leftists who
championed Fidel Castro no I mean just
know you can be against authoritarian
and against US intervention I was not a
supporter of Fidel Castro but I was
against the embargo on Cuba these
positions can be held simultaneously you
can be in favor of social democracy but
against so-called socialist
authoritarian regimes which are really
authoritarian perversions right that
that's actually what they are in
practice and I'll actually go even
further you can argue in general about
what type of aid is good for a country
like if you're displeased with the type
of aid that is being sent to Venezuela
you believe that instead of sending food
we're better off or they will be better
off if we send the equipment and source
materials for making their own food I'm
right there with you right we've been
talking for years about how a lot of the
types of aid that is sent around the
world
manot Aryan aid free sneakers for
example which gives people sneakers for
a little bit but it does nothing to help
them build a footwear industry and in
the long term it's of questionable value
that's a perfectly legitimate debate to
have if that's your problem with the
humanitarian aid that's being sent but
this is Bernie Sanders this is not some
wild neocon interventionist chill of the
types that wanted to get us into the
Iraq war and other intervention so let's
all think for a second let's calm down
for a moment I am thrilled that Bernie
has stated his position whatever it is
it just so happens that he is absolutely
an exactly spot-on with this position
now if you're going to write to me let
me throw out a disclaimer if you're
gonna write to me in there and say David
but your view doesn't align with that of
for example Venezuelan funded state
media you know what you're right my view
is not going to be the same as media
outlets that are funded by the Maduro
regime that that's not gonna be a shock
but you should also consider whether you
believe that the equivalent of North
Korean state television or Trump TV is
where you believe you are getting the
most precise and accurate description of
what it is that's going on in Venezuela
good for Bernie if you disagree with the
facts let me know why I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we will take a quick
break
boy is it a good program today on this
Monday today's show is made possible in
part by Sun basket giving everybody in
our audience 60% off their first box
when you go to get Sun basket calms
slash Pakman you'll get six dinners
delivered to your door for just twenty
eight dollars son basket is a meal kit
service that brings fresh ingredients
for ready to cook recipes to your home
but they are not like some of the other
companies that you might have heard
about because what makes Sun basket
different is their commitment to
sustainability which I know is really
important to lots of people in our
audience organic ingredients USDA
certified
antibiotic hormone free meats as well as
an ability to accommodate just about any
type of diet if you are low-carb if you
are gluten-free if you are paleo
vegetarian vegan pescetarian
Mediterranean Sun basket has you covered
or even if you're not sticking to a
particular type of diet Sun basket has a
lot of great plans to choose from
just pick a meal plan choose how many
recipes you want per week you can even
choose which recipes you want before you
get them so that you know you're getting
meals you'll enjoy and the list of
recipes changes every week you can also
choose when the meals show up at your
home which is really useful for me in
particular you can even skip weeks if
you need to everything that needs to
stay cold stays cold everything stays
totally fresh all the ingredients are
pre measured which makes everything
really easy for you and all of their
packaging is recyclable and compostable
which I especially love start getting
sustainable delicious healthy organic
meals sent right to your home and get a
60% discount off your first week of
meals just by going to get Sun basket
comm slash Pakman you'll get six dinners
delivered to your door for just 28 bucks
I've put the link right underneath this
video